the monsterverse has in its bank a lot
of monsters that have appeared in both
the movies and the comics
and also some that will make an
appearance in the big screen sooner or
later so on this list we will talk about
the 7 mammalian monsters
that have appeared in skull island the
comics and kotm
we have already done a video about the
flying titans and the aquatic titans as
well
so we will now focus on the kaiju that
are more related to us humans as
we are all mammals too we will exclude
the ordinary animals
and also we will exclude the titans and
other creatures that are not really
confirmed
or have a high chance to be in the
mammalian superclass
of course we are all thinking about gong
but believe me there are others as well
so check this video out and subscribe if
you haven't since we have quite a lot of
viewers that are not really a part of
our family
yet so let's go with number one
death jackals the first on this list are
the death jackals also known as the
spiny mortum
they are mammalian slash reptilian kaiju
that first appeared in the monsterverse
comic skull island the birth of kong
these death jackals resemble a cross
between a large dinosaur raptors
and wolves or hyenas with long limbs and
hair like spikes
they have long snouted reptilian faces
and a spiky mane
running down the back of their necks it
is unclear if they are primarily bipedal
or quadrupedal
as many individuals are seen missing
some limbs they have the agility of a
leopard and the bite force
of a great white shark these are one of
the most hyper energetic creatures on
the island
they are also hyper carnivorous and will
devour their own kind if a meal is hard
to come by
they are believed to be seven to twelve
feet tall and twice as long
number two the icarus tigress the second
one on this list is yet another large
mammal carnivore of skull island and
this one resembles an overgrown white
bengal tiger
but with a footprint length of 5 feet or
1.5 meters
and a height of around 14 feet tall some
depictions of the bees
have huge stag-like antlers while others
have curved
elongated teeth similar to saber-toothed
cats
icarus tigress was the only one of many
creatures not to be featured in the
film's
tie-in comic series skull island the
birth of kong although it will appear in
gvk kingdom kong
due to release in 2021 it has reddish
black stripes running throughout the
body and its face is tinted a bright red
with a pair of palish blue eyes also
known as a holy tiger
they are elusive and almost mystical and
they seem to avoid direct contact with
humans
number three the scare buffalo next we
have the scare buffalo
seen in the 2017 kong skull island movie
this animal is a very large water
buffalo which is quite harmless
and more or less a gentle giant these
giant skir buffalos greatly resemble
abnormally large water buffaloes but
with several differences
they possess incredibly large horns that
have forked into at least three branches
the scale buffaloes also have algae
covering much of their bodies probably
due to their habit of being underwater
their backs are shaped like coral and
this physical feature allows them to
camouflage
with their surroundings these bees are
around 20 to 40 feet tall
way larger than an elephant or a
non-surprise dinosaur
they can use their massive horns as
powerful and dangerous weapons against
anything
that they perceive as threats number 4
titanos kong
i bet we all know who he is by now but
let's see what monarch has to say
standing over one hundred feet tall the
beast de galcon is a primate of such
size and ferocity that his very
existence rewrites every chapter of
evolutionary theory
more mountain than mammal he walks
upright on two legs
his towering form shaking the ground
with each thunderous step
it is hard to say how kong has existed
but initial analysis of bone structure
and teeth
suggests that the creature is still an
adolescent he is still growing
although the 2017 kong was in fact from
the 1970s
the kong from the comics birth of kong
was twice that height at around 200 feet
tall
and in 2021 when he comes face to face
against the g-man he will rival
the size of godzilla himself who stands
at 400 feet tall
and this will make him the largest ever
incarnation of the character
number five titanos behemoth this
was an original kaiju created by
legendary for the 2019 godzilla king of
the monsters movie
he was in fact a mammalian island that
was created so that kong wouldn't be the
only one of his animal superclass
in existence behemoth resembles a
prehistoric ground sloth
with large curved dust resembling dose
of a mammoth
he is covered in light brown fur while
his head resembles that of a mammoth
with a short taper like trunk he has a
row of serrated
granite spines fortified with metal and
ore running down his back
and he has brought fingers bearing very
large claws like an anteater
with the high limbs being started for
weight so that he can walk by pedal if
he wants to
behemoths dust also appear to have some
sort of green algae
or vines growing on them one peculiar
thing is that his skin is bulletproof
and even fireproof as missiles
and weapons of humans didn't absolutely
nothing to him
and he stands around 354 feet tall
almost the same as the size of godzilla
2014
number six daytona's sekhmet this titan
called
sekhmet is a giant winged felid kaiju
created by legendary pitchers that
appears in the legendaries 2019 film
godzilla-looking of the monsters
as her name was briefly seen on a
monster screen
during the awakening of the titans by
ghidorah's alpha call
whereby they all went on a rampage and
started destroying humanity cities
one by one in mythology sekhmet was a
goddess of war
and a son and was depicted as a lioness
whose breath was set to
form deserts in the most verse she is
believed to have the appearance of a
sphinx
or a giant lioness but before the events
of kotm
and at some point of time back then
sekhmet had a monarch
outpost designated number 65 built
around her in cairo egypt
nothing much is known about her except
that she destroyed a railway during kotm
and number seven titanos camazotz this
is the last mammalian monster on this
list and this one is none other than
titanoscanistas
as we just said a long-awaited entry of
the monsterverse and this kaiju will
make his appearance
in a 2021 comics gvk kingdom kong
and here he will dwell with kong before
godzilla has his chance
camazotz is a massive cream-colored
creature with demonic horns
and facial features that looks like a
bat obviously
as well as large bat like wings covered
in long sharp spikes
he also has what appears to be black
colored fur covering the entirety of his
torso
and parts of his neck his jaws are
filled with dozens of jagged dagger-like
teeth
and at the end credits of the movie one
of the images
shows a bat using echolocation and it's
a possible reference to camazotz
he will also be another entry into the
group of flying titans which includes
mothra
rodin the male muto and others like the
shinomura
and with that we come to the end of this
list of the seven mammalian monsters
healing from legendary's monsterverse
so tell us what you think and if we have
missed out number eight
then put it down there in the comments
below and if it's true we will pin it on
top
so leave a like for support and
subscribe as well as smack that
notification bell as well
smack it hard smack it like you mean it
just smack it
right on the floor smack it give me some
[Music]
more
[Music]
[Music]
you